[音楽]
前歯で bb
分
私の今日の話のテーマを越境をですね
列強といってもいいですね海外に行くとかそういう話じゃないんですね会社とか組織の
中で
影響する話をしていきたいとおもいますちょっと時間軸をまず坂登りまして
当時ついてもまあ今もそうなんですけれどももしソフトウェアを作る仕事をやってるん
ですね
で今と違うのは当時はですね結構大きな組織に所属していて5000人から1万人
くらいの人がまあ集まるそういう組織でやってたんですね
ソフトウェア開発だからダメだというわけではなくて大きな組織だと結構ありがちなの
がお互いに何故ているかよこ
からないということがこの会社でもあったんですね
でそうなるとそれぞれやってる仕事ってなかなかうまくいかなくて
大小様々みんないろんな問題を抱えながら実際仕事をしているってそんな状況だったん
ですねでそういう状況の中で自分がどう思ってたかというと俺は悪くないというふうに
思ってますね
もうみんな失敗してるの
がうまくいってないのは好環境のせいだとをロワーを
うんも忘れ失敗したと思うでも自分のせいじゃないというふうに思ってますねで
えーっ
きっとまたどうか違うところで自分が活躍できる場所があってそこにいつか言って
やろうってことをずっと考えたんです
ところがそのどっか行ってしまう前にですね私は事件に遭遇してしまうんですね
でその事件っていうのが自分が関わったプロジェクトが炎上してしまったんですね炎上
って言葉はメス援助ということもありますけれども
制御不能になる
ってことなんですよねでまぁ仕事でやってますから
いつまでに何をやり遂げなきゃいけないという約束事を果たさなきゃいけないんだ
けれども
炎上プロジェクトではそれがもう危うくなってしまうと正直どうなるかわかんないそう
いう状態なんですね
でこの炎上プロジェクトってもっとやばくなる状態があってですバーチって言葉がある
んですね死の行進ですねもうミリー聞く
聞いただけでもヤバそうな感じがすると思うんですけども
もうこうなるとですねもう本当にこれやった方がいいのかと
もうこれここまでしてやんなくてもいいんじゃないかって関係者もだんだん薄々気付い
てくるんですけれども
まあそれでももう最初にやったから問いかけあれとそこに時間も人もつぎ込んでいて
やりきることが目的になってしまっているそういう状態のことですマーチ戦です
でまぁ当然大変ですよそんなプロジェクトなのでで僕もこのプロジェクトやり遂げた時
にこれ二度とやりたくないなと思ったんですね
健康もそりゃあ銀行に悪いですし
で思うのはいいんですけれども結構その炎上プロジェクトっていうというのはプロあの
結構日常と隣り合わせなんですねプロジェクトの条件がちょっと変わっただけで仕事
追ってアップもやあの思い始めるのでいつも隣り合わせなわけですよ
じゃあなんかすごいマネージャーがいて私のところに来て仕事やプロジェクトを整えて
くれていい感じでは助けてくれるかというと
まあこれはタワーが妄想ですよねこれを持ってもちろんもズームわけにいかないと
その時初めて気付いたんですよこれ俺何とかしなきゃいけないと思った
自分で自分のことをそうでないとこのまま時間を割きを口にして言って
対しの文たことをやったとしても何も解決しないとことに初めて気づいたんですね
でじゃあ何とかしたいと仕事を改善してきてプロジェクトやり方を変えたいというふう
に思ったんだけれども
自分はそういうスレじゃないしそう会社の中にそういう中根ヒントがあるかっていうと
みんなトラブってますから
ないわけですよでじゃあそうなると会社を外に行くしかないって思ったぜ中の会社外に
出て行ってそこにあるいろんな
知見を得振りにフレーク触れていこうというふうに思ったんです
でやっぱりそのこの業界のいいところなんで
けどその会社を横断して勉強会とかカンファレンスとが結構たくさんあってその自分が
こんなことをしてこんな問題時はこうなったとかっていう数値権を知れる
バーってのが結構あるんですね僕もそういう所に行っておくやいいなといろんないい
ことが聞けると
で確かに自分の現場に戻ったときにこういうのやってみようっていうふうに思う事が
たくさんあったんですね
立法府でそのいろんなに話を聞いていくとどんどんと自分はもう嫁はしていくんですよ
何でも屋目指していくかっていうと自分は何があってたのかっていうと何もやってない
なってことにようやくそこで気づくんですねこのぽいが自分の中でどんどん膨らんで
くるんですよ
で冒頭で言ったように僕は環境のせいにしてますからやってないっていうのは
もわかっているんです
でそこで会社をカードを継続するとかって言う前にまず自分がいる場所で会社を
ちょっとでも良くしようということをやってみようというふうに思ったんですね
ここでその思いを新たにしたんです
でへと何か変化を起こすとかその越境していくっていう人はたいていそうだと思うん
ですけれども
何かをやるその活動点は大抵一人で始めなきゃいけないですね
なんでかっていうとあの人っていうのは何か現場が問題があるというふうに気づいて傷
からこそその次行動を起こすわけですね
じゃあ誰も行動を起こしないということは誰も気づいてないわけなんですよ
だから
私もこの時仕事をやり方を変えようという活動を始めたんだけれども一人で始めざるを
得なかったですねまぁもちろん一赤蟻ずつ元なんでその中央 n 4めんどくさいと何
のためいろいろ
過去の質問を寄せなるわけですでまぁそれに応え切れるわけでもないのでまぁ自分で
じゃあ一人でやっていくかってことになると1人でやっていくとだんだん心が荒んで
くるんですね
誰も巻き込んで込まれてこないから心折れてくると
となると自分のやっている活動っていうのもどんどん中途半端になってだんだんこう
途中で終わってしまうってことに
によくなってたんですねでこれをまた何とかしたいというふうに思ってまた同じように
会社の中では特にピントがないですから
その外にそのヒントを求めに行くわけですねであるイベントに参加したときにその
イベントが自分にとってすごい変換大きなきっかけになったんですけれどもその
イベントっていうのが何用ではなくて
帰り道がいつもと違ったんですねえっ
帰り道なのでそのままいい話を聞いてじゃあしたから自分の現場に戻ってまた現場にも
仕事に向き合うってそういうシチュエーションですか
そこにふと気づいたらまあ同じ会社に所属している同僚がたまたま一緒の帰り道にいた
んですね
であっああさっきふと気づいたんですよ
このイベントに参加しているってことはこの人も同じような問題意識を持っているんだ
よなと
同僚ですから同じように会社に戻って自分と同じ会社に戻って
でなんとかしていて思いに駆られて何とかしようとして挫けるって事をやってるんだよ
なというふうに気づいたんですねダップがこの2人目をまず巻き込んでみるってこの
から始めたらどうだろうと思ってますね
4武将とか会社とかそういう大きな単位で何か変えていくっていうと仲がその巻き込め
なくて一方が住めないんだけれどもその2人目このまず
つまり電車で帰ってます加工隣の人を巻き込むのでやれることからやっていこうという
ふうに思ったんです
そうするとまぁこの人っていうのは僕もその後ような高越境する活動をやっていった
わけなんですけれども本当に最初の2人目になって外に何を思ったかというと
最悪この人がいればいいやという思うんですよねその3人目4人目というの
を巻き込んでいくんだけれどもさっき言ったようにですね大抵抗を簡単に巻き込まれて
くれないと
一人になると心折れてくるわけですけれども
2人目がいたら少なくとも1人ぼっちがなんですねだからそのここで折れる時間が
なくなるということで前に進めることができると
っていう風に言うと者2人目がすごい特別な人だったんじゃないかって思われるかも
しれませんね
でも僕は2人目は実は自分の周りに一度もいるというか誰もが不法自分の2人目になる
ということにこのとき気づいたんですねっていうのはその何か変化を起こすか影響
するっていうとは大抵背負いこんじゃってですね自分でお菓子オレオやるそうだった
オレが世界を変えてやるぐらいのこと思うわけですよで大みんな俺について来いた
で俺が全部じゃなきゃいけないっていうふうに思い昆布ですね
つまり周りが見えてないんですよででも
っていうかそんな状態だと誰も巻き込まれてそれはくれないですよね巻き込まれにくい
じゃないですか
だからああ確かに理想となぁ
ところは遠くにあってそれをを忘れずに見せるんだけれども
でもその手元でやるのは自分に感心を持って少し
集まってきてくれた人たちといこの人たちと何ができるかっていうのを考えてコードを
再定義することによってその鉄橋というのは前に進むんだということが惹き付けたん
です
でえっ
今日っていうのはさっき言ったに1人から始まることが多いとでも一人で始めるのも
結構いいところですよ
例えばアスターから朝会をやりたい明日から振り返りをやりたいというふうに思ったと
してじゃあ部署でやるから
中に20人の合意形成をしてそれでようやく明日から始められますのでこれやったら
そんなこと一時充てる時間いくらあっても足りないですよね
のでまず一人で自分でやるで中
のチームの人を少なくとも巻き込んで前に進めるということを
はやりやすいので一人っていうのは越境をする時によその最初の1本としてはな
実際んですよね
でも一方でそこから先に行こうと思ったらそれを
部署だったり会社とかにそういう影響を与えようと思ったら自分一人はやっぱり難しく
て自分と同じように旗を振ってくれるの2人目を見つけないとどうしようもないんです
ね
二人がいると当然ですけれどもこう時間も倍になるし
考える頭が動く体を前になるのでどんどんやれることが増える
ですねそれによって1強が進むとん
で実際僕が何をやったかというとその2人目の人と社内で仕事を改善するための
コミュニティをつくったんですね
そのコミュニティで日夜勉強会をやるということを活動として始めたんです
でこれがまあ二人目がいたからこそうまく進みまして
あっという間に100人くらい集まったんですね集まるようなコミュになったんです
で
100人って結構大きな人数に感じるんですねまた先3人目4人目巻き込むのに
なかなかできないなと思ってたくらいですから
で102といった時に版会社的な活動してるわけじゃないけれども誰かが100に混ぜ
て何やってんだっていうふうに文句言ってきて解散させられたらどうしようとかそう
いうことを考えたりするんです
でもその時思ったのはまた思ったのは
まあ最悪解散されてもいいかの棒2輪がいるし
この2人目と3人目4人目を巻き込み直すような活動をまた始めたらいいんじゃないか
というふうに思い直して活動を止めることなく実際誰からから止められることもなくて
先へ進むことができたんですねでまぁやっていくなかでこの活動自体がその会社に
閉じこもる必要もないなということに気づいて業界の中のコミュニティと一途という子
好きで活動を続けていこうということを今もやっていてそれが2人から初めてには
5000人集まるようなコミュニティがあっていいですねこの場にはどういうとこ
集まってるかというと
社内で越境したいあるいは会社を飛び出して違うことをやっていきたいてそういう人
たちが集まっていて僕がその外にヒントを求めに行った時はこんなゴミになかったんだ
けれども
今だったら後潜入がかりで5001人目の人に対してこういう風な経験を元にこんな
ことをやっては移動ですかっていうのヒント
ご提供できるようなそんな場所に立って言っています
ということで私の話をこれでちょっとまとめたいと思いますけれども
京都の一人で始まりますとってか一人で始まった方がいいもあります
でもそこから先に行くためには2人目の力が必要でその時に思っていただきたいのは
その変わるスピードっていうのは人それぞれ違うんだってことですね
自分と同じようなスピードで勝ってほしいと
思ってほしい行動もしてほしいと思うんですけれどもそんなのはですね
もう一それで違いますそれを認めた時に初めてその周りの人を受け止めて前の人と一緒
に何ができるんだろうというのはちょっと考えられるようになるのでそういう考えを
持って皆さんもそれぞれの影響っていうのを進めていただけたらなというふうに思って
います今日はありがとうございました
[拍手]